okay we have a voicemail number that
number is two one nine two david p ever
since my story earlier this week about
Donald Trump and his drawer full of
sudafed which coincides with what people
have said who spent time with him on the
apprentice that he's regularly eating
sudafed and snorting adderall a lot of
voicemails like this one saying David
you are absolutely right and I'm glad
you're talking about this hey David I
just wanted to call and thank you for
finally starting to say what is actually
going on with Tom he's not crazy he's
not unhinged you know all these words
that we use is clear to anybody who has
been in the addiction industry or has
been addicted to any sort of amphetamine
is that he he's high and coming down and
high and he's coming down really high
and he's classic everything that he does
is is what that is and the sad thing and
the scary thing is he's not gonna get
better there's only gonna get worse so
just yeah so listen it he may still be
unhinged and all of those other things
but he also may be addicted to
amphetamines we don't know for sure we
may never know for sure but so many
addiction professionals getting in touch
and saying David I think you're right
I've been observing this for a while and
I think you're absolutely spot-on we've
got a great bonus show planned for you
today become a member or a patron to get
instant access